let me welcome all of you to session two
of the classic metal class and looking
at the news today I realized that it's
actually kind of a fortuitous day for
for having this because we are going to
be discussing Ronnie James Dio and his
place in what we can call the Sabbath
purple Nexus and this is the ten year
anniversary of his death one of the most
powerful singers in heavy metal ever and
very instrumental and in you know moving
things along is we're gonna talk about
and unfortunately you know he's been
gone all this this time so this this
class all of you I think have been here
before but I I'm gonna say this for
people who are just tuning in to the to
the video this is a class that's focused
specifically on classic metal we're
talking about metal in the 70s and the
80s and we might talk about beyond but
it's going to be connected into the 70s
and 80s stuff in some way or another not
so much about the genre stuff that that
spirals out later on and you know I'll
be doing a good bit of music history
I've got Scott here to help me out with
that as well and I'm also be tapping
Scott as my music theory person and
somebody who's a practicing you know
guitarist I'll talk a little bit about
it but his accomplishments in a minute
but so we'll talk about some music
history stuff I've also got some
philosophy focused things I want to
bring in as well and you know we'll also
have a good bit of back and forth
discussion and we we reserved a good
amount of time for Q&A and discussion
afterwards hopefully some of the things
that we're saying will be
thought-provoking and the the topic that
I wanted to talk about today is
something I've been thinking about for a
long time and I've called it the the
Black Sabbath deep purple maxis now not
that that's like a recognized term it's
just I don't have anything better than
that so if people have other suggestions
that might be a good way to put it and
and what I mean by that is that these
two particular early heavy metal bands
that were really instrumental in the
origins of heavy metal also ended up
functioning as a kind of matrix within
which people were brought in and and
spun out and a number of other bands
wind up emerging from that that
themselves were both influenced by these
earlier bands but also are going to be
exerting a considerable influence
themselves on the formation of the genre
and it's good to remember that you know
this term heavy metal has never been
totally agreed upon and what it what it
means or where its boundaries are and
it's not really being used that much
until like the mid to late 70s and and
it's being used in a retrospective way
so actually one one thing before we get
started I did do a little polling of all
of you before we started the session
when you signed up for it and Scott
hasn't they actually seen this so it'll
be interesting to see Scott's reaction
to this as well I asked which of these
bands do you consider to be classic
heavy metal and I let people pick as
many as they wanted and these are all
the bands that are on that that handout
that I created so Black Sabbath
everybody considered that to be classic
heavy metal interestingly deep purple
eight out of nine votes so some people
were like I don't know and it kind of
depends on what what albums you're
looking at right stormbringer by the
time we get to that late stuff you know
it's it's it's a little bit debatable
then the two that were next were
blizzard of Oz or Ozzy Osbourne as a
solo act and do seven out of nine people
said that that was classic heavy metal
five out of out of nine so now we're
getting to where it gets really
controversial said that rainbow was
classic heavy metal and then Whitesnake
only two people
and Gila and who I think a lot of people
said no because they don't they don't
actually know that much about the band
Gillan right which and there's there's a
good reason for that that we could go
into later on one of the good reasons
for that is that the vagaries of iTunes
and music services it's it's hard to
actually get the stuff that you want to
get there were some issues with releases
anyway back back to the topic so so the
nexus that i'm talking about is is this
this connections between these two bands
and their musicians and all the other
bands that are flowing into them and out
of them i think that it's helpful to
talk about some philosophical topics in
relation to this like that of causality
an agency and this this hard to pin down
the thing that we call influence musical
influence so we're gonna we're going to
go into that a bit and we'll talk about
how these things fit in with each other
so first let's let's talk about the
nexus itself our last session our first
session we we we noted that there were
some really seminal early heavy metal
bands and they included the oftentimes
talked about is like the trinity of
black sabbath deep purple and Led
Zeppelin but there's also UFO budgie
uriah heep all very important at the
same time sir Lord Baltimore soon
afterwards in the United States a flower
traveling band and in Japan and when we
look at how the classic metal domain if
we want to think about it as sort of a
interlocking set of relationships how it
develops there's connections that are
that are worth noting between a lot of
these bands one of these that were not
gonna talk about today would be UFO and
the scorpions and Michael schechner
where they essentially poached the young
guitarist who probably would not stay
have stayed have the scorpions anyway
judging by it by his later actions and
activities and
and statements but they you know they
they turn him away and that led to some
things sir Lord Baltimore being
connected with Black Sabbath is another
great example they opened for Black
Sabbath when Black Sabbath comes over
across the Atlantic and starts touring
in the United States closer to our topic
let's consider do and I haven't actually
remembered that is a 10-year death
anniversary was coming up when I started
taking notes for this but but if we
think about the trajectory of this guy
Ronnie James Dio he starts out with this
band elf and elfs first album is
actually produced by two members of deep
purple Roger Glover and I in pace and
then they're absorbed into rainbow some
people actually talk about it as being
cannibalized and eventually Blackmore
fires everybody except for Dio and
brings in his own people and then do
plays this incredibly influential role
in the songwriting and the performance
of rainbows first three albums and then
he leaves and joins Black Sabbath
invited in by Don Arden and his
soon-to-be estranged daughter Sharon who
we know as Sharon Osbourne he's there
for two albums then he leaves forming a
solo band bringing Vinny Appice out of
Black Sabbath with him and forming this
this new connection which included
people like Vivian Campbell and Jimmy
Bain some really important musicians who
you might say it had some apprentices
already so he's kind of a representative
figure of of something in this nexus he
doesn't you know originated in the Nexus
he's not in Black Sabbath or deep purple
originally but he ends up you know
becoming part of it and then you know
you might say sort of like an ode
attracting other things around it plays
a central role in it later on so a
significant portion of what we think
about is classic heavy metal comes out
of this Black Sabbath deep purple Nexus
and you know we've got these two really
major seminal Bay
we've got these other bands that are
spinning out or spinning off of them and
I wanted to think about if we think
about the years 1983 to 1985 as sort of
taking a little slice of history at that
time what do we have we have Black
Sabbath trying to line up with Ian
Gillan and producing the album born
again and going on tour and having their
spinal tap moment of not being able to
use the Stonehenge stuff on stage it was
actually too big rather than too little
and then Tony Iommi ends off going out
on his own
Black Sabbath effectively disbands after
born again on the other hand we have
deep purple reuniting and forming / you
know the perfect strangers mark to line
up and probably their most successful
album to date Ozzy Osbourne is recording
some really solid solid records at this
point in time with with Jackie Lee as
his his main guitar person do is putting
out great record after great record as
well
Whitesnake is moving from their earlier
bluesy stuff to more commercial metal I
was never a big white snake fan I'll
mention too by the way but I see them as
an important part of this this whole
picture and then rainbow at the same
time what's happening to rainbow in 83
to 85 they're not a metal band anymore
even though they get included in metal
anthologies for you know some of their
stuff but they've effectively become an
AOR pop band so you know those are some
of the interesting cross section bits of
that history and the other thing I'll
say about the Nexus is odds are if you
listen to one of these bands you
probably listen to others of these bands
and if you're influenced by one of these
bands you're probably influenced by some
of the other bands as well so this is a
good lead-in and here's where I'm going
to Tapscott oh and I forgot to mention
Scott's Scott's achievements and
credentials so that we're joined by my
good friend and colleagues got to
rouille who is a guitar professor at
Berklee School of Music but that's
just sort of the the you could say the
least of his accomplishments he has
three albums to his credit at this point
in time and might be working on another
one you might talk about that a little
bit later on and he's played as a studio
musician or as a game musician with an
incredible array of people not just
within the scope of heavy metal or hard
rock but also all sorts of other genres
of music ranging from jazz to
contemporary classical lining up with
dancers to funk to R&B so he's somebody
who he is very interested in metal we're
both you know essentially from the same
matrix of the of the 80s right and we
talk a lot about this and in our
conversations but he's he can also bring
a lot of very useful music theory and
music history to bear so let's talk
about this this idea of musical
influence what what does this actually
mean and how does it work and I'm not
going to try to provide anything like a
comprehensive analysis here of what what
influence could possibly mean but let's
start with this Black Sabbath and deep
purple when you look at other later
bands like for example Iron Maiden
you'll see you know in addition to other
bands the members of Iron Maiden's
saying yeah it was really influenced by
by this person or this band great
example of this Bruce Dickinson not
really you know that focused on Black
Sabbath he said that his biggest
influence was Ian Gillan of deep purple
so how does what does influence actually
mean what does this produce how does it
actually work is it just sort of like
something that we take laughs on a set
of boxes or does it mean something
in reality and so you know if we think
about how it actually functions I think
that a good part of it has to do
with what would in philosophy we would
talk about cause and effect or causality
and you know if you think back to your
intro to philosophy classes or those of
you who actually do more philosophy
think you think about you know say
Aristotle and then Seneca is letter 65
we we often distinguish a number of
different types of cause and effect or
causality and Aristotle famously
distinguished four different kinds and
and each of these is an answer to the
question why what's going on what is
happening how can we wrap our heads
around it and so you know we're mostly
used at this point in time as late
modern people to thinking about cause
and effect as this sort of thing like I
pick up this paper and I tear it a bit
I've changed it in some way and we say
okay what's what just happened there I
caused a change in this that's what we
call efficient causality I produce
something I bring something into being
or destroy something I changed something
in some way another example that's often
used in philosophy classes is you hit a
billiard ball and it hits another
billiard ball and makes it go in the
pocket okay you've caused things in that
way we could talk about whole chains of
causality and you know if you're
thinking about musicians maybe you know
Ritchie Blackmore who is a big causal
agent telling Ronnie James Dio you can
do this thing or you can't do this thing
and you must do this thing we can look
at that as kind of efficient causality
does influence really work that way I'm
not convinced that that it really does
instead we might think about other kinds
of causality and this is where I think
ancient philosophy without providing us
all the answers can at least be helpful
in giving us some some guides so
Aristotle talked about material
causality what something is made of and
you know we could think of things like
this cup being made out of porcelain and
the tea and the cup being made of water
and the fragments of tea and you know
all those sorts of things
but when we're talking about me
music we're talking about something that
has a materiality to it you know we hear
it it's it's registering within our
minds it's not something that's purely
you know spiritual and in the sense of
being disconnected from our lived bodies
and all of that but it's it's harder to
explain what the matter of the music is
at the same time we can say if we want
to speak in an analogous way we're not
speaking in a one-to-one exactly you
know you niffle way but we want to speak
and analogically you know when we talk
about here's where i'm going to turn it
over to scout a little bit when you talk
about a musician being influenced by
another musician let's take a tarus and
well as we'll take somebody who we've
talked about it personally quite a bit
ritchie blackmore very influential on
several generations of guitarists i
think you can say what are they actually
taking from him part of it could be
thought in terms of form structure right
but some of it might just be the sound
itself or something else that's kind of
at a lower level so so what do you think
about that Scott well I thought a lot
about it we should make a distinction
between three words influence okay
inspiration hmm imitation so let's take
I like the Aristotle so the efficient
cat causality might be somebody seeing
the Beatles on Ed Sullivan now they
might so they see this possibility of a
rock band you know people can be in a
band like before then it was people like
Elvis it was so that might inspire
someone to pick up a guitar you know
like Steve Lukather and everybody has
talked about that directly made them
pick up the guitar now they're not gonna
sound like the Beatles right so that
would be I guess
Aristotle's what you call direct
efficient cast causality no I would say
we could talk well yeah so so efficient
causality is you make something do
something right material causality is
what the thing
made of insofar as that helps you to
understand what's what's going on and
then we can also talk about formal sort
of the structure that's imposed on it
and so here's where let me suggest this
you you're sitting there as many
guitarists did back in the day and many
basis to and you're listening to the
album and you're playing along with it
right and you are on a formal level
you're trying to imitate what is what is
happening at first and then you start to
make it your own your guitar is not the
same thing as Ritchie Blackmore's guitar
as a matter of fact you may not even be
able to get your guitar sound player if
you're playing with the settings and all
that sort of stuff the material is not
the same but you're imposing the same
formal causality onto it over over time
you could say and it gets closer and
closer and closer the pattern if it's
done right I mean I've seen people
directly well I mean even Stevie Ray
Vaughn early on dressed like Jimi
Hendrix and played the same licks as
Jimi Hendrix and Albert King no so he
was somebody that was actually imitating
and then just as a byproduct he came
into his own voice so I guess the the
big thing is if I'm influenced by
something I could be listening to it and
there might be a hint of it or it's
inspired me to go somewhere but you do
see clones you do see people that
directly copy what they love so that's
like that's one thing but yeah
inspiration and influence inspiration
would be the Beatles like you don't
sound like them but they've inspired you
to go out and do this thing called music
influence might be well I've done all
these brizi Blackmore souls you know I
would always argue Yngwie well you know
it depends on what day you ask him I
mean he got the Marshall we got the
strat yeah a moves on stages ritchie
blackmore but then of course he ended up
in they started to do his own thing so I
would say he started out like you said
imitating and that grew into something
else
so those are three words that I
generally use to distinguish whether
somebody's being a clone
somebody's just been inspired like you
know your next-door neighbor has a
guitar and you thought it was cool so
you get a guitar but then you get into
something else
yeah now another another aspect of
causality that Aristotle talked about
but I think you know sometimes it's hard
to figure out exactly what's going on
because it winds up being a lot more
complex than he often presents it but he
calls it final causality what is the
purpose what is the point of doing
something and Aristotle himself very
much like things to have one point or
purpose
he actually criticizes a certain kind of
knife that some people used that's
almost like a Swiss Army knife because
it had too many different purposes to it
in the politics he talks about this in
an offhand remark but you know as human
beings we we are constantly engaging in
action that's intentional and very often
we have happy accidents you know one of
these happy accidents that actually is a
gonna tell the story a little bit later
on would be how Black Sabbath ended up
recruiting Ian Gillan by all of them
getting drunk together welljust Butler
and and and Yomi and hanging out with
Ian Gillan and then by the end of that
night somehow they decided that they
were actually going to form a new Black
Sabbath and then Ian Guillen's
manager actually called them up and said
what the hell are you doing you don't
make these decisions without me so
clearly they they made a decision so
sometimes you have happy accidents but
even there you can say well what was the
point of that they want to make great
music together they think it would be
you know they could work together well
there's all of these decisions that are
being made and I think that when we're
talking about this Nexus there's all
these opportunities for people to see
you know chances for what they want to
do fitting together and then at a
certain point sometimes it doesn't work
anymore that's all like Dao has to leave
rainbow because he and ritchie blackmore
can't see eye-to-eye on the musical
direction musical direction is a
teleology it's a final causality of you
know trying to produce this sort of
thing and there can be a lot of
different motive
at play you know want to make some money
it's nice to have groupies the music
itself is fun to do want to you know
become a big star all those you know
could be compatible or incompatible you
know another great example this is of
course one reason why deep purple breaks
up is because they not only are they
losing musical direction but they're all
some of them are getting high as kites
Glenn Hughes on cocaine and Tommy Bolin
on all sorts of other things and not
being able to function anymore so
there's there's that going on and I
think that when we're talking about how
things are working in this nexus we can
talk a lot about the influence that
these people are putting on each other
not just in terms of musicality we can
also talk about important producers and
managers fitting in there as well and
some of these musicians played a role in
that
so Tony Iommi for example actually got
got involved in creating a management
agency by about 1973 that was very
interested in promoting a band that
never went really anywhere but also did
managed Rudess priests for a short time
as well and then later on the owe me is
going to really in getting involved in
producing the band quartz one of whose
members Jeff Nichols will end up you
know playing for Black Sabbath later on
and being involved in in that whole
scene quartz is one of those bands that
never quite made it in the new wave of
British heavy metal we also see that
that the the people involved in deep
purple were doing quite a bit of
management and production as well and
and one of the things I'm going to take
a little side shuffle here and talk
about something that may not seem very
metal at all but but was actually quite
instrumental so there was a show called
the butterfly ball and grasshoppers
feast and it was done as like a stage
show but it was also done as a cartoon
and it was put together by originally by
John Lord who you know is the the
organist of deep purple and also a great
composer and he wasn't able to
completely see it through so the bassist
Roger Glover saw that stuff through and
he had all these people singing for it
and some of the people are both will
show up in deep purple later on the
David Coverdale of Glenn Hughes Ian
Gillan saying for it and so did Ronnie
James Dio eventually you know once do
joined Blackmore he had to cut off his
association with that / Blackmore's
insistence because Blackmore like to run
everything but I saw it recently in an
interview with do when he came to
Australia and this may have been the
case in other places they didn't know
him originally as the singer of rainbow
they knew him as being involved in this
kids cartoon which was quite quite
popular these sorts of things brought
people together and I think that we we
have to think of what's going on within
this nexus as a number of different ways
in which musicians are being brought
together brought into discussions and
connection with each other jamming with
each other
and I think the other thing that we want
to think about is the function of these
bigger bands in the Nexus bringing in
people from other bands that I'm going
to call feeder bands sort of like in in
major major league baseball or you know
NHL hockey there are feeder teams at the
lower level who send off their players
if they're really good enough to the
major league so like here in Wisconsin
we have the AHL that's American Hockey
League the milwaukee Admirals and they
are the feeder team for the I want to
say Nashville Predators or Memphis
Predators one one of those other teams
right that that's like the big league
and so if you're good enough at playing
hockey here then you know they're
keeping an eye on you and eventually
somebody's gonna say you need to play
over here for the Predators not good for
the Admirals when their talent leaves
it's not good for any of these other
bands either like trapeze
where they got Glenn Hughes or you know
some some of these people went in and
out of different things Bob Daisley is a
great example he is in this band called
Widowmaker and then he moves out of that
into rainbow and and plays her Ozzy and
and actually plays for your right heap
for for a while as well well that's not
good for Widowmaker and we can go down
the line there's there's a lot of bands
who talent is getting poached from you
know that's that's kind of a an
interesting feature but then there's
also a correlative Lee bands getting
spun out so originally we had Black
Sabbath and deep purple and you know
these these very vital influential acts
but not allowing after that more on the
deep purple side than the Black Sabbath
side but eventually Black Sabbath is
going to get into the act we have these
other bands getting spun out of it and
that's part of what I have for you there
in the handout the most influential
bands coming out of that matrix and it
comes about because people don't want to
stay in the same bands so if you think
about deep purple who's the first person
to leave the mark to set up of deep
purple well it's Ian Gillan
and why does he leave it's not that he
doesn't like playing with the purple he
and Ritchie Blackmore can't get along
and Ian Gillan talks about this again in
interviews and he says well anion Roger
Glover came in we were treated like the
new guys as if we're just sort of hired
hands well that wears on people who have
significant talent after a while and are
doing some you know contributions to the
the songwriting and so he leaves an
event at first he forms a jazz fusion
band that we're not even really going to
talk about I mean some of the if you've
ever listened to them maybe some of the
worst things that you see in spinal tap
at the moment everything for that are
inspired by that but he's after that he
will form another band called Gillan
which is a you know very solid you could
call it hard rock
I actually think that a lot of what
they're doing is arguably metal they
never managed to really go anywhere in
part because they aren't able to catch
on in the American market but they were
quite big in Britain and Europe and
Japan and you know so that that was that
was quite important rainbow of course is
going to come out of Blackmoor himself
getting upset and leaving the band and
why is that going to happen
well after Ian Gillan leaves Roger
Glover gets fired
he'd essentially been there with Gillan
and Blackmore fires him Blackmore was
you know he was very much of it all sort
of trumpian you're fired kind of kind of
guy apparently and they bring in some
other people they start you know
recruiting new talent they bring in
Glenn Hughes from trapeze which is not a
metal band but you know it's playing
hard rock and Glenn Hughes is a double
threat he's a bassist and a singer so he
can contribute quite a bit and then they
bring in this guy who at that time was a
total unknown he's never actually played
in any commercial band
he's just playing in pubs David
Coverdale and that you know revitalizes
deep purple Ritchie Blackmore didn't
like the direction that the band was was
taking he very famously says a racist
remark about them playing shoeshine
music and then departs in in a huff and
by the time that he's doing this he's
already connected up with Ronnie James
Dio and a band elf who if you remember
had been produced by some of the other
deep purple memberships so now we're
starting to see these interlocking
things Ritchie Blackmore takes over elf
and brings all of them in as essentially
his band decides that the only one he
likes is do fires all the rest of them
and then brings in some other really
important players like Jimmy Bain from
Scotland who again is being promoted
from the minor leagues up into the you
might say the
you know the top notch acts he brings in
Cozy Powell who's gonna play a major
role in Black Sabbath as well later on
and you notice that that rainbow goes
through a number of different lineup
changes throughout the 70s in part cos
Blackmore keeps hiring and firing people
he brings in Bob Daisley from Widowmaker
fires him eventually and that brings in
Glover from deep purple that's no longer
around
by that time they did buried the hatchet
and eventually will will actually deal
will leave and and you know take take
the band will take a completely
different direction meanwhile at the
same time what's happening with deep
purple they they go on they have to find
another guitarist so they bring in this
guy again who'd already had a background
who done some solo acts by himself who'd
been in some other bands Tommy Bolin and
it unfortunately didn't didn't really
work out because Tommy Bolin by that
time had a significant drug habit as did
Glenn hears and the band you know by 76
they hang it up they say okay we got to
quit and later on 76 Tommy Bolin will
overdose so oh you know it was a serious
habit meanwhile David Coverdale after
the band breaks up he goes on and forms
his own solo band that solo band will
eventually become the Whitesnake band
just a bunch of backers of David
Coverdale but then he'll actually
reconfigure it and create the band
Whitesnake which if you've ever listened
to their older albums they're they're
pretty bluesy you know most of the songs
are about having sex in one way or
another with the exception of some
romantic songs about soldiers of fortune
or there are things like that but it's
you know it's it's it's pretty decent
stuff it's arguably metal in in at
certain points and he's recruiting more
and more people you know Bernie Marsden
plays a really important role John Lord
is there with David covered a a lot of
people don't realize that John Lord went
from deep purple into White's me
and stayed there for for you know quite
a long time cozy powell will play with
them for a while there's there's a
number of other people coming in and out
and eventually he's going to bring in
John Sykes who will help to transform
the sound of the band from the more
blues oriented thing and to a sort of a
pop metal band that we all know from the
the mid 80s and the famous Whitesnake
self-titled album meanwhile you you know
well although this is happening
you've got other things going on on the
side with with Black Sabbath largely
because of I mean it's kind of funny if
you think about this if Ozzy Osbourne
hadn't been the colossal you know a
Craddock 'script that he was maybe a lot
of this music history would have
developed quite differently and I've got
a few things to say about Ozzy and you
know being an agent of change rather
than being you know sort of the passive
recipient of it in just a moment but
what ends up happening as we all know is
by 1979 they've had it with him and he
gets fired and now they have to find a
new singer and you know the last several
Sabbath albums had been kind of
lackluster their tours were were not
quite up to snuff you know van Halen
kind of upstaged them on one of their
their tours as often happens with young
and hungry bands and I think kiss they
actually opened true that as well doing
the same sort of thing
they bring in Ronnie James Dio and why
do they bring in Ronnie James Dio well
because he's available and because
Sharon Osbourne at that time Sharon
Arden knows Wendy do and they you know
talk with each other and and do goes
over and at first things go really quite
well
Bill Ward by that time has left so he
gets replaced by Vinny Appice the
younger brother of Carmen Appice who you
may know from Vanilla Fudge Vinny Appice
same sort of thing had played in other
bands getting pulled up from the minors
into the Mae
now imagine getting to be part of Black
Sabbath right although the band was was
only a little over ten years old at the
time it really would have been quite
quite a thing so you've got this this
new setup of Sabbath that puts out two
really really solid albums goes out on a
new tour is able to bring a new energy
and dynamism and put Sabbath back up
there along with these these other acts
that are going on and then eventually
you know there's there's there's
conflicts and clashes in part because
Yomi and Butler were clashing with with
do mostly over over like you know who
would determine the direction of the
band and do interestingly enough had a
record contract already sort of like a
in your in your back pocket kind of card
Warner Brothers had told do anytime you
want to produce a solo album will work
with you on that
and the idea was that he'd probably stay
in Black Sabbath but he'd do a solo
album on the side with his friends and
it'd be a one-off kind of thing it'll be
a lot of fun and he he thought about
that and he was like you know actually I
can like just start my own solo career
which is what he did he brought Vinny
Appice with him he recruited Jimmy Bain
and interestingly enough now here's
remember I was talking about producing
as an issue so when we think about
Jackie Lee we think about him usually in
terms of Ozzy Osbourne and then some of
his later things like you know red
dragon cartel and and all of that right
JK Lee was a major player within the LA
the LA music scene and a lot there was a
lot of confluence between the what's
going on in the British music scene and
the LA music scene because they're all
playing over there
JK Lee was first in a band called Mickey
Ratt which then of it later will become
rat and that's not even the most
interesting part of this he's also part
of a band called rough cuts who produced
rough cut Ronnie James Dio who managed
rough cut Wendy do
so when do is forming what's going to
become his his supergroup for his solo
thing Jay King Inc was the first person
that he was considering the only reason
why Jay Cayley didn't join and why I do
ends up going with Campbell instead is
because Jay Keely goes over to Ozzy
Osbourne's band and so you've got these
really interesting connections that are
going on now
Ozzy Osbourne's band I mentioned that
that I'd say that Ozzy was less of an
agent than some of these other people I
mean do is very definitely knowing what
he's doing Tony Iommi definitely knowing
what he's doing Ritchie Blackmore you
know yeah he even deep purple at their
worst were probably more in charge of
what they were doing than Ozzy was Ozzy
just kind of goes along for the ride the
person who's making most of the
decisions is his wife and manager Sharon
Arden and later Sharon Osbourne and she
you know I think all of you know the
stories about the band that she
organizes originally the blizzard of Ozz
who include some really important people
Lea Kerslake on drums Don Airey on
keyboards Bob Daisley on bass and of
course Randy Rhoads
on guitar now where did Randy Rhoads
come from poached from Quiet Riot he's
the reason well I mean Ozzy's band is
the reason why Quiet Riot doesn't go
anywhere and breaks up for a while
because they lose Randy Rhoads Rudy
Sarzo will eventually join some of these
bands as well getting taken from Quiet
Riot and Ozzy's band doesn't really stay
in a stable configuration there's a lot
of movement in terms of the rhythm
section and the keyboards people going
in people going out a lot of that had to
do with you know songwriting and sharing
you know credits which means sharing
money and and I think some of you know
about the lawsuits that that leaker
slake and Abdi easily had to had to
bring against the the Osborne's it
wasn't enough to prevent Bob Daisley
from coming back to work with Ozzy later
on and for example bark at the moon and
you know I mentioned jakey me well when
Randy Rhoads dies JK Lee is the person
who is II recruits but there was
somebody else who was also up for
contention who Scott ICU knocking who
was it dear me remember well in between
Brad Gillis finished the tour hmm so
Brad Gillis tells actually what's that
there's somebody yet more famous though
that was up for the chair before Jake I
don't remember at the same time is JK
Lee George Lynch oh right I mean think
about what I mean Jackie Lee is great
but you you think about these
counterfactuals like what would it be
like if George Lynch had stepped in
there what would it be like with Gio's
band if JK Lee had been there instead of
Vivian Campbell you know a lot of these
these what ifs come up yeah you know I'm
gonna actually bring this to to a quick
close there's this this long sort of
history thing and remark about we could
say that this era you know one of the
camps on it is Black Sabbath essentially
breaking up and Tony Iommi bringing out
you know seventh star in in in 86 Tony
Iommi at that point didn't want to call
it Black Sabbath but his record company
said you have to call this Black Sabbath
and he's bringing in all these people
including by the way Glenn Hughes
meanwhile at the same time we have a
white snake going strong do going strong
Ozzie going strong and we don't have the
Gillan band anymore why not because Ian
Gillan has rejoined a newly you know
formed mark to again deep purple which
goes on tour and just knocks it out of
the park so you know when we when we
look at this what do we see with this
this
I mean it's happening over a period of
years but these people are coming in and
going out and coming in and going out
and a lot of them are you know imposing
a kind of shaping or formation onto
these bands determining the directions
that they're going to go like I said you
know Ozzy less so I mean he's usually
you know kind of just taking whatever
comes and doing the Ozzy thing which you
know you did quite well but he
definitely needs what what in ancient
Greek we would use this term arcane
determination ruling causing in some
respect from other agents and I think
he's drawing that in part from the
musicians the very very talented
musicians that he's he's playing with in
the case of Black Sabbath I think you
can say that geezer butler and Tony
Iommi are the constant members who are
determining the sound no matter who you
bring in whether it's do whether it's
you know Ian Gillan whether it's later
on Tony Martin or or Glenn Hughes there
is a consistent Sabbath sound arguably
less so once Butler leaves right but you
notice Bob Daisley will join Black
Sabbath for the eternal Idol and so all
these people are getting pulled in cozy
powell will play with Black Sabbath so
can we talk about this as to come back
to the main point as sort of a nexus a a
network of interconnected people that
helped to produce the heavy metal scene
as we know it in the 1980s I think I
think we certainly can and I know we
haven't gone very deep into like the
nature of causality or things like that
but I thought that this could be an
interesting topic I know I've gone way
way way over time Scott hasn't talked
much let me let me turn it over to Scott
for a minute get his reactions about how
this and then we'll start looking at
some of these comments and questions
well you know you touched upon a point
about the British sort of the British
three coming in and then
kind of cross pollinating with the Los
Angeles seam I mean yeah Brad Gillis J
Keely I mean now you're starting to get
what's going on in LA with the classic
metal and I think you you mentioned like
83 to 85 yeah I mean you have to I'm
thinking like you know we've said this
in the past you can't really address it
this time is blatantly but the sound
started to change
rainbow started being a little more AOR
a little more melodic with Joe Lynn
Turner I wouldn't say a little that yeah
right I mean yeah you know bringing in
Joe Lynn Turner and you know who's an
American guy and I think you know we
there's a few things that change the
sound in as you say like it kind of it's
still metal like you have Whitesnake and
they were important because they were
the first present metal band that
mastered the Led Zeppelin sound without
directly copying them like still of a
night is clearly a thing but it's clever
with all the modern touches right yeah
where's bands like Kingdom Come right
branded has just clones and that's no
limitation yeah yeah and we even knew it
at the time but you know I things at
play like in 83 like turbo you and we
have mentioned last time well we also
have the the next wave of technology and
then more music has happened since then
right you know if you're looking in the
late 60s really aggressive blues maybe
you call like like the first Zeppelin
album and it becomes heavier yeah and
then these bands start but then a lot of
music happened outside of metal in the
70s in the 80s that they were listening
to also are they were aware of and I
think somewhat organically went from
okay we still have heavy guitars heavy
drumbeats
but we've got a little more of a bigger
chorus you know like Def Leppard really
started with a big band with pyromania
with the huge courses oddly jd-u not JC
Lee Blanc you know he went to Def
Leppard a visiting Campbell isn't oh
yeah yeah
so it's kind of funny that that he's
kind of like ended up there and actually
he was in Thin Lizzy for a while wasn't
he
Campbell I think he did Finn Lizzy for a
little while yeah so what you I think
part of this Nexus is part of the sounds
we start bringing in the people from Los
Angeles where we're real melodic rock
started happen in the 80s and but more
music existed I don't I'm not saying
they did it but like you know they could
have had a Todd Rundgren record or they
could have had the suite or something
that was kind of a little more over the
top with in quirky so more music existed
to draw upon so you have the but no
technology where the producer said this
is the cool new thing they're not analog
keyboards anymore we have this dx7 which
is like a digital keyboard you could
that everybody is using Simmons drums
and and then amps just from a gear
standpoint up until the 80s if you want
to gain out of here have you had to turn
it up all the way and you put the tubes
into distress and that gave you a
distortion well as effect pedals came
you can take a clean amp at lower
volumes so then choruses which is an
effect in delays and echoes started
coming into the digital realm where
these people started to adapt it and
then you know somewhere it's something
extreme like somewhere in time that was
nothing like peace of mind yeah yeah but
we have the introduction of technology
we have the energy we have these people
you know in the LA meeting with the
Brits and the news new sound start
happening I would say 83 is fair enough
to say that's kind of the beginning of
it by 85 and those last half of the
decade know another thing that is I'm
looking at this most of these bands you
know we can talk about certain
configurations we have the power trios
like Motorhead originally and Ravin and
well even cream b-before metal right and
then we have like the you know two
guitar bands like made and and priests
and and so many others and then we have
like the you know four piece where
you've got you know drummer bassist
singer and and guitarist and you know
whenever the guitar is soloing the bass
has pretty much got up the holding the
whole thing together
most of these bands are through through
a good part of their career with Black
Sabbath being the exception and
Whitesnake also being an exception just
because they put so many people on the
stage our five piece single guitar the
other guitar is an organ or a keyboard
you know like what's do for example on
the first album this guy schnell is not
actually credited as being like a member
of the band although he's playing the
keyboards and you know would Holy Diver
are rainbow in the dark be what they are
without the keyboard playing definitely
not and by the second album he's
recognized as an integral member of the
band and and you know you could look at
the purple I didn't you know we didn't
talk about Uriah Heep but they also kind
of figure in there as one of the central
configurations when you look at a lot of
the other like la bands there are some
that have keyboards but not that much as
a matter of fact ruffcut kind of sticks
out as one of the LA bands that did have
keyboards rat didn't motley crue didand
Quiet Riot didn't I mean they have some
keyboard parts occasionally but they're
not you know in the same thing like van
Halen right they they have some keyboard
parts but that's not integral to the
early I would say the early van Halen
sound until 1984
so exactly right yeah you know yeah I
mean by 85 I think well you know we
could say kiss too you know by the time
oh yeah yeah yeah no well you know maybe
crazy nights wasn't the first one but
that was keyboard heavy yeah the early
the early New York and we could say like
East Coast bands not an awful lot of
keyboard in there
riot you know a great example yeah Oh
tool I guess so you know after you know
the analog keyboards at the time it was
just you needed somebody that really
knew how to dial in a sound yeah but
yeah I mean I think you're right or you
know well van Halen yeah 1984 and
of course 5150 when Hagar came in Eddie
was actually playing a lot of keyboards
on right right yeah
well cuz he could because nah somebody
else's can do the rhythm guitar that's
right perfect yeah yeah well let's let's
take any sort of questions or
accountants there's a lot of comments on
the side including links to the
butterfly ball my grasshoppers feast
which indeed was a book that was then
adapted as a musical Oh what must have
been quite something
all right a lot of stuff in here from
Chris about different ways to understand
causality let's take the one from Arash
we talked last week about genre and
brought up the vic contingent family
resemblance notion for connecting ideas
seems like the notion of musicians
influencing each other has a similar
logic of integration and evolution of
different related musical ideas yeah
it's and it's not so much about defining
i would say in this case it's more about
like tracing what's happening to what i
think another thing we can say with all
of this this discussion of causality is
there's very little that's like you know
absolutely determined by this thing
happened this way so then this thing had
to happen this way like you could say
okay well you know Ronnie James Dio
could join Black Sabbath because he left
rainbow but there's nothing in leaving
rainbow and not being able to get along
with Ritchie Blackmore after a while
that necessitates him going over to
Black Sabbath it turned out to be quite
quite fortuitous that did and he talks
about this again an interview saying how
much he learned from Ritchie Blackmore
and how much he learned from Tony Iommi
and geezer butler and being on stage
with them and doing the songwriting but
but there are all of these yeah all
these intra intersecting connections and
the other thing that Vidkun Stein says
in the work that this typically gets
brought out of his philosophical
investigations he talks about well you
know what is the essence of a like a
rope there's no one single
shred that goes through the entire rope
but instead it's it's a whole bunch of
of you know connected fibers and so if
you if you try to figure out just this
one single one you you mistake things
it's sort of like you know when people
are like well happy metal began with
this song right here and then it you
know proceeded in this very linear
fashion no it's always much more more
complicated than that and I think that's
that's where it becomes quite quite fun
and we can say this about other genres
of music as well like you know what's
the originating piece of jazz I don't
know I mean I'm not a I'm not a versed
in that at all but I would venture to
say that there's probably a lot of
different things going on that are
connecting with each other and so the
challenge is being able to provide some
intelligibility to this that goes beyond
saying well this sounds cool and these
these must be connected in some way we
want to be able to say how are they
connected right what do you think Scott
I mean I guess the bottom line is if
you're talking about kind of the
switching of players and the different
bands and how the music involves yeah I
mean obviously I would say it's the
contribution of the musician so in other
words even though Ozzy Osbourne was a
solo act every player on like died of a
madman or blizzard of aahhhs is part of
that sound I mean not all sonically but
you know Randy Rhoads was like really
studying the Leo Brouwer pieces when he
was studying classical so died of a
madman it sounds like a Brauer piece to
me so you know how he got a different
California guitarist that wasn't
listening to Leo Brouwer we wouldn't
have that haunting die of a madman kind
of thing yeah although Ozzy's kind of
the boss the frontman and you know even
down to how the rhythm section sounds
what remember when I think you alluded
to this when Sharon redid died of a
madman but what she did she took in
modern players and replaced the rhythm
parts and I think I think it was route
Rudy Sarzo who she replaced Bob Daisley
stuff with the drums drums and bass are
replaced by like nine grunge guys and I
remember buying that and talking to my
friends going this isn't the album at
all but but Randy was Dylan Ozzy was
still there which goes to show you the
rhythm section was a big part of that
sound so you know you could talk about
songwriting and you talked about
technology we talked about you know it
could have been something as easy as hey
check out this record and you hand it
off at a rehearsal and that becomes part
of it mean the influence but now that's
probably the best example I can think of
is replacing the rhythm section on a
classic album we have Randy Rhoads you
still have Ozzy's performance but it's
not the same album so and you know that
makes a good sense
yeah they so they had multiple takes to
get it right they tried to copy it but
they can't you can't you know what's
kind of it's kind of like well you talk
about like Charlie Watts for the stones
and you know people will put him down
yeah but if you put a different drummer
on those records they wouldn't be the
same or they put down Ringo Starr well
he was doing something right and so it's
this whole I think it's a really good
point that then yeah the Nexus or maybe
like the fact that you know this person
coaches this band is gonna change the
the sound of the band and most people
might not know why well the bass is a
little heavier the rhythm sections more
locked up now so we tend to think of the
lead vocals and the screaming guitar
solos but it's not necessarily one thing
a great example of that is like Bill
Ward versus Vinny Appice you know Oh
Vinny Appice is much more on the beat
you know or you know cozy powell
as well or any of the other ones and yet
when they when they're interviewed they
talk about Ward and they're like he was
he described himself as a percussionist
rather than a drummer and he was a great
one you know there's there's a certain
style we've talked about this before too
of like Nicko macmaine McBrain sorry and
Clive Burr okay technically speaking
McBrain is a better drummer
but Kleiber is more fun to listen to you
know because there's that looseness and
jazz eNOS to it you know oh yeah I think
I think he was you know he was more
solid I mean I think the band was really
I don't know I really I mean I love all
all of me but the early records even
with Dianna Paul Dion oh yeah it's a
different it's more like progressive
punk I don't know I'd like to see what
they would call it yeah because they're
because the barrier thing yeah oh yeah
because he had a different yet a
different more direct style I guess
Nicko you know it's kind of like more of
a showman and like all over the drums
but I listen alive after death all this
time and the times kind of all over the
place but it doesn't matter it's uh it's
just think it's kill I'm glad they
didn't go correct it yeah it's a good
thing they used to get with let's let's
take chris's a question here about album
recommendations so best albums to listen
to by rainbow
Whitesnake and Gillan so you can deep
deepen your knowledge of the Nexus and
one of the best albums of the entire
Nexus Sabbath the Ozzy and deep purple
so let's take the rainbow one first if
you let's and let's make it let's make
it tougher right you can only pick one
rainbow album instead of saying well
listen to the first three you can only
listen to one of them which which is it
and I won't tell you which one it is for
me cuz I want to hear from you first
Scott we're just one I mean we have the
Joe Lynn Turner era so it would be final
vinyl okay I think you know cuz it's got
the I think it's the live ones
it's the deal oh yeah yeah 77 is it is
it the kind of cheating though to make
it the life because when you have a
concert right it's it's like some stuff
from this album and some stuff from this
album that's sort of like saying
Greatest Hits you know you know and I'm
I'm a big disqualifier a bit like you
know so he says just buy it but the
thing is final vinyl have killer
performance I mean
there wasn't doctoring it's like in the
I think deal women said that the live
record which they reissued what eight
years ago neo on it is I mean the
performance is yeah much I mean I I mean
if you're saying to start I mean I would
pick Randall rising amazing I mean yeah
yeah there's not a bad song on the whole
thing I know and I got that classic one
yeah and it's got that it's all it's all
arguably serious metal you know and in
it I think it also it's influencing a
lot of people as well
Whitesnake that's a tough one for me cuz
I'm not really a fan of Whitesnake if
there was just one that you would say
the person what would you say you know
oddly enough I would say I mean I would
say the 87 self-titled with John Sykes
okay because the reason I say that is
yeah you're right previous to that like
even slide it in as the before is kind
of a bluesy rock and it's a great record
yeah I really think that the 87
Whitesnake album what really defined it
was kind of like all these bands from LA
were trying to do the post Zeppelin
thing I think this album the production
is is amazing yes there's keyboards on
it but John Sykes is an animal yeah
covered alien voice and and then you
know after that with the Vaughn with a
vie album I was a little letdown it's
not that it was a bad album but yet
early on I you know I don't have a lot
of the earlier records I've slide it in
and for us that's that's when Whitesnake
became big they came on the scene in the
80s I mean they were there definitely
churning away but I for from my research
it looks like a lot of people considered
them essentially like a continuation of
where deep purple had been because
Coverdale had been so important in the
later deep purple stuff you know
oh yeah life stuff you see on YouTube
with him singing when he sang Byrne was
73 yeah I mean he was on fire great
great performance
yeah and that's interesting too because
he was not one of those people who had
been sort of trained up within these
let's call them you know feeder bands or
apprentice and bands
he was just like straight out of the pub
see they're like let's get this guy you
know just a side note on Coverdale that
I found out from Red Beach he was
telling me that he was go back and
listen to the demon Coverdale speak he
had this really horrible cockney accent
and if you notice now he sounds like a
very proper British you know he has that
deep but I guess he he where he went
you know speech he got speechless Oh
interesting so now when he speaks he
sees mr. eloquent
you know yeah yeah so but like you go to
the early interviews and it's like
almost unintelligible cockney and he
joins the metal scene and gets more posh
you know yeah well you know as it caught
on I suppose it's a way to climb within
society you know I mean Ritchie
Blackmore too you know he and his
constant emphasis on you know medieval
music that's kind of along all the same
lines now as far as Gillan I can give a
recommendation about that its glory
wrote that that was the album that sort
of like finally clinched things for the
Gillan band it's not always available
and there are these other things that
are called the Gillan tapes that were
put out by other members of the band
part of why the band broke up and didn't
work out all that well as they had all
these disagreements about like as many
bands do about royalties and who's
getting paid at what time and that sort
of stuff but but at glory road is a
really good one I think that one was
from I want to say like 80 or so now
what about the others what about Sabbath
this is tough
not let's expand it with Sabbath so we
can we can pick two albums as like the
best to listen to not not just to like
have fun but like to learn this
this nexus I mean I think well you have
to pick one of the Ronnie James Dio ones
really you don't think so well go ahead
well I mean this is so hard it's kind of
like you know you know this is funny
this is a great question Chris because
you know it's kind of like well what's
the best van Halen album and I would say
well are we talking to Rafi best Roth
album or the best Hagar album so those
you know what I mean for me that's a
non-starter like I don't like van Halen
so you know right I know but um yeah but
I do have an ant I would have an answer
for each thing so it's you know uh the
Ozzy or the do I mean I think that he it
would be good in terms of what we're
talking about here to listen to like one
of the do ones because that way you're
you're getting a sense of how how
different the stuff is right I mean you
know that's that's yeah exactly and you
know that goes along with the whole
thing of Nexus is thus it's a
essentially the same band right yeah
call me with a different front person or
my person or their voices are wildly
different oh yeah you know if I were to
pick one of the Ozzy arrow ones and it's
tough to do I would probably say Sabbath
bloody Sabbath because it's midway
through their their time you've got a
lot of really good songs on there that
are showcasing the kind of stuff that
they could do you know yeah that's it's
a classic it's a total classic record
it's a great one
what year was that do you know Sabbath
bloody Sabbath 73 74 somewhere somewhere
yeah it's really it's I mean it's early
enough on that they haven't lost their
fatality
well like by the time what was it never
say die by the time that came like that
look like phoning it in that's when you
can actually have Bill Ward singing on
one of the songs because as you refused
to sing the song like is that what
happened it's interesting to listen to
yeah but it's you know it's it's not
great no and you can even tell by the
cover that they just kind of like adisyl
this will do
I mean it just looked like a kid put it
together yeah I mean that and technical
ecstasy there are a few songs on there
there that I like I don't think they
deserve to be as panned as badly as they
do I'll tell you another thing too when
it comes to Black Sabbath
it wasn't mixed well but I am really a
big fan of born again the cover album is
terrible or the cover art is terrible it
was actually voted like one of the worst
album covers of all time
Ian Gillan himself you know I guess the
the the tour did not go well because he
had trouble remembering the Sabbath
Eurex but the album itself is is pretty
good and it's got one of the heaviest
songs ever zero the hero which is you
know a great song trashed is another one
that Ian Gillan really liked so it's
it's it's unfortunate didn't turn out
better than it did but that's production
you know like the money production like
you know even that's a it's an
interesting point because productions
not always a deal breaker just to jump
to the 80s I remember when white-line
came out with that album pride and they
had no budget and it sound like it was
recorded in his trash can but the songs
were so good that you would did you
would listen to it but had the songs not
been so good that yeah I mean another
good example of that is venom right
their first album is just the one of the
worst production things you can hear but
there's there's something going on there
you know production turns into kind of a
charming thing if the songs are so
strong kind of if you want to say that
what you're doing is they're like
post-punk I guess right people would
speak of it as the real rawness right
exactly yeah but what about what about
deal if you had to pick one do album
what would it be oh come on
and it can't be Holy Diver
I mean it's tempting to pick Holy Diver
because it's so good I mean you know
this is not gonna be popular oh okay let
me think why am i blanking out it was
the one from 86 with rock and roll
children and king of rock and roll
that dream evil no that was before dream
evil it was um
am i blacking out they could hurt take
her heart yeah yeah yeah that's that's a
good one I love that album actually he
said he loves that album too
Oh interesting I mean you know you're
not the one I like the best is is
actually last in line no I mean I love
that record yeah yeah oh god yeah it's a
and you know Vivian is so important not
just because I'm a guitar player before
I was really you know serious Vivian's
guitar solos he took his time and he
hung on notes and it was kind of very
lyrical very miracle in kind of like I
you know he he was very unique like that
if you got somebody else on that on they
would have filled the 16 bars with a
flurry of notes but there's yeah hot
team you heard the echoes kind of going
off and then his vibrato and he would
wait and to me that was like brought the
magic to he'd complimented this the do
stuff yeah but on every record that he
played on I get a say you know I'm
always listening to the bass and Jimmy
Bain my stuff is just an amazing bassist
who rejoined yeah and part of what I
really liked about those those albums
was you know if you think about like the
typical basis they're like they're
constantly playing something and and it
could be something really great like you
know let me playing the the thing that
he does which is halfway bass and half
way rhythm guitar because he's holding
down the that whole end there or it
could be Steve Harris you know oh like
constantly getting stuff off and then
with these amazing fills that are
different from every single you know bar
to the next but what I liked about Jimmy
Bane's bass playing on dioz early stuff
is and it's similar to by Daisley
they're it's the spaces it
the places where he's not playing
anything and just letting there be a
rest and then coming in with that really
hard punchy bass that like pulls
everything along with it it's I mean I
don't have a better way of describing it
but I think that's integral to that to
that whole sound well oh go ahead before
you go on I just I don't want to I think
deal is one of those people that kept
putting out great albums killing the
dragon was that yeah three that's an
unbelievable record and actually master
the moon was a fantastic album what was
it was was it Magica before that one
with the sounds right yeah mm and you
know those I put those up you know some
people are like oh it's got to be the
first few albums in Diels case he kept I
mean I killing the dragon became my
go-to list well I I think that has
something to do with with a guy himself
I mean he was a master musician he could
play all the instruments if he wanted to
but he he you know he just didn't he
pulled other people in to do it he's
probably going by the interviews that
I'm seeing with him he's probably one of
the smartest guys in in rock and roll
you know when he brought him Doug
Aldridge for that record who was
integral part an LA guy and Doug is a
beast like his feel and you know I
respect Craig Goldy very much but I
don't think I thought his guitar playing
was always great but it didn't hit me
the way
Vivian did or doug aldrich really has
this you know it's just like I always
say it's you know killing the dragon and
then I bought the DVD of the tour where
they played most of the album and it was
just you know I mean you're going to the
guys like at the time was 62 or
something and making his best stuff and
sounding better yeah the only the only
thing I did notice about deal I'll say
this is that we gonna we gonna take the
next one about Ozzy is when you listen
to some of the later live recordings he
has to he has to go down a couple keys
because his his voice and like so many
other people's had had you know lost
some of its rights range but he was so
very powerful you know okay so what
about Ozzy and let's say that we
restrict
- like the you know 1980s I say stuff
you got to pick one album which is the
one that you you pick for me that's
tough I mean if I had to do one it would
be dire and madman yeah that's tempting
each one has its own its own kind of
distinctive why it would be the the best
representative album to it I actually
want to say bark at the moon in perk
because I like JK Lisa much well you
know I would say ultimately that's and
it's a really good one to you know wait
what you don't have an ultimate sin is
Bob Daisley and Don Airey right and you
notice that although the two main people
that people have called the guitarist
and the singer and I keep saying the
rhythm section is gonna make or break
you
yeah I mean it's a good it's a good
rhythm section on ultimate sin but it's
just not manok it I don't even say that
it's second-rate it's just like one and
a half right I like I think there's more
better songs on ultimate sin than bark
at the moon market the one has some
great songs but more misses to me yeah
yeah it has it has one terrible song
ballad the other thing that that is and
this is a total side note Ozzy Osbourne
writes his own lyrics and he spends a
lot he spends more time than any other
big-name musician I know
whining about how bad he's got it and
how misunderstood he is and that I mean
that's on every single album pretty much
in the 80s and there's probably more of
that on bark at the moon than there are
the other albums
laughing now what about deep purple you
can pick one one up too and he can't
pick perfect strangers you can pick one
1970s deep purple what would you pick I
love burn that is a good one
I love burn and you know I when I go to
the classic stuff I crank that
it's a great great rift I mean the tune
itself but the whole record has got that
sense but especially if you have it on
vine on you have a good system you did
it's got that Sonic what about you well
I you know I mean I like the ian gillan
stuff better so I would probably say
machine head that's a great album
although it's I mean it's tough there's
a lot there's a lot of really great
albums in that section and I do like the
stuff with Glenn Hughes and David
Coverdale
stormbringer is pretty good too
you know I listen to come taste the band
the other day and you know that's the
one with Tommy Bolin and I wasn't super
happy with it but I think it's it's it's
less about Tommy Baldwin and more like
the band was just not coming together as
well by that point what's funny Tommy
ritchie blackmore tells a lot of stories
about Tommy they were friends he
actually really respected Tommy Bowen
and Tommy called him up Wednesday and
said come over check out my guitar and
so he went over there he said there was
no furniture in Tommy's house and he
pulled this guitar and Blackmore said
the strings were filthy and he said to
Tommy are you gonna change these strings
and Tommy said should I and he couldn't
believe that like this great guitar
player like you know had no idea about
that but I like a player a lot I you
know I thought it was great it was great
the time he was in the band in a way
it's it's it's as if he was in the wrong
place at the wrong time you could say
you know right which which happens a lot
I think in in in the history of music
all right let's let's see Carl has oh
here's a couple different things Carl
says I love the cover art for born-again
I think it's highly amusing well yeah I
mean you're you're in a minority I'm
like I don't mind it myself but man a
lot of people really hated it including
the band it was a surprise to them
another sort of spinal tap moment yeah
Chris Morris he says strange highways
1993 is underrated I'd say that's that's
true oh that girl says
hypnosis was great it's amazing how many
covers they did and how so few people
who own these records know they're
designed by features models members of
throbbing gristle I don't know anything
about that
yeah no fuss force it is a great example
that's recently deceased Genesis Pete
Orage and Cosme Fanny Tootsie on that
sleeve okay what are you gonna say oh no
I I'm not aware of that one myself chris
says technical ecstasy is hilariously
bad though so we're talking about the
album cover there which shows two robots
copulating and it's not a sexy robots
copulating like like an heavy metal
magazine or something like that it's
these two block key things has this
thing kind of arching to the other one
and then we had a one straight and a lot
of people are looking at it they're like
what the hell is this supposed to be
like hey rock the robot remember
remember rock the robot from Y&T keep on
running well you know this is a bit of a
side note to but i you know i've been
i've been using Apple music suggested
for you to like find old new bands that
that I knew to me but old that were like
popular in the early 80s and doing doing
interesting metal but then just never
like came together some of the album
covers are just amazingly bad we should
we should probably do a thing on the
aesthetics of album covers at some point
in time you know like what makes an
album cover cool as opposed to
off-putting or just no good you know
that that could be an interesting test
yeah you're right now that we're
thinking about it's like the the
shocking covers and some of them I had
nothing to do with the title they were I
mean yeah you know I have to think and
write a list well you know it's it's
interesting too we could talk about
controversial album covers like you
think about scorpions virgin killer
right you can't get virgin killer which
is a good album you can't get it in
iTunes and I'm convinced it's because of
the
you know the problem with you know
having this they had another alternate
cover but they had this underage kid on
the album and you know all the
connotations are pretty much bad
Whitesnake got a lot of heat for one of
the early albums
what was it call it some something I
mean it's got this woman's essentially
naked woman from the back sitting on a
giant snake so it's typical white snake
you can't get more more phallic than
that that's like spinal taps velvet
glove right yeah exactly
yeah and it changed the cover which a
lot of bands did I mean the first
Electric Ladyland Jimi Hendrix was just
him with his guitar dressed up on this
kind of Hill with like 20 naked women
and it went out and it's a collector's
item because so if you happen to buy
that first run it was you know even back
then yeah you had to change it or even
houses of the Holy
the Zeppelin oh right right alright that
was a controversial one yeah well I
think maybe it's so that'll definitely
be a topic that we we talk about be a
fun one the future yeah so Andy says I
think we sold their soul for rock and
roll while a compilation is the best
Sabbath if you added orchid solitude and
into the void for master reality it
could be perfect yeah I mean that you
know it's interesting that I mean the
first Sabbath album that I ever had was
born again cuz I ordered all my stuff
through the Columbia record Club that
those of us who are old enough to
remember you would like you know send in
a penny and you get like eight or nine
or ten depending on how they did it
albums for you know like a penny and
then they would like send you this stuff
each month and if you didn't send it
back they charge you for these these
albums and born-again was one of the
ones that I got in when I when I first
signed up for it and then I bought we
sold our soul for rock and roll when I
was down on spring break in Panama City
Beach
freshman year would be 1985 and I got it
out and I put you know had a boom box at
the time and I'm listening to this I'm
like holy crap this is amazing stuff you
know and I think I'd heard some of the
songs
four on the radio when I was younger but
you know as a young teenager it was it
was quite some heady stuff but it is a
compilation it is the best title you
know I I don't know
Chris says master reality was my gateway
into Sabitha a long one that his first
love yeah yes covered are there are
there any good Black Sabbath covers III
have to think about that
I mean mob rules is kind of good but
Black Sabbath has had their share of
pretty bad covers in charge of that
because most of the bands we find out
after the fact yeah apparently the story
with sabotage is the band didn't even
know they are gonna be photographed that
day they just had somebody you know the
coming in and taking pictures Don Arden
was the manager so and he was a pretty
you know tough guy everything's gonna
happen my way so he probably just like
told the Fatah girl up the band will be
here you know all right guys get in line
and we'll do that Carol says I love the
cover of paranoid something really
beautiful to the naivety of it yeah and
you know originally supposed to be
called war pigs and and the cover
actually made a little bit of sense yeah
right right but then once they decided
to call it paranoid there was no
connection between the name and the
actual imagery that's a great example of
what I was saying before like sometimes
the image would have nothing to do with
with the album you know like well you
take a love at first sting okay that
makes total sense yeah it kind of tells
the story right remember you know we
remember records they we'd have part of
the story and then the back yes you know
there was always a first and second part
of the and sometimes they'd fold out two
or they'd have like the album notes and
things like that where there were things
that make sense a little bit although a
lot of the references they you know
thanks to Jimmy the the thumbnail digi
you know or something maybe who the
hell's this person to the
Thanks yeah you know if you think about
it
Deep Purple's album covers there they're
pretty straightforward you know come
taste the band there's a chalice there
you know storm bringer there's you know
the stormy sky with a blimp in it I
remember right how does these album
covers obviously it's it's him
except for ultimate sin right well that
weird-looking from a spandex demon lady
which makes it appear he's a shot in the
dark video Oh interesting yeah I don't
think I've ever seen that no rest for
the wicked was kind of an interesting
cover but you know like yeah deals album
covers are pretty consistent in their
style you know absolutely yeah so yeah
you didn't have any I mean Sacred Heart
the one I said dream evil they make
total sense I mean just the the
sentiment oh I'll tell you I'll tell you
a funny story I think I've told this one
to you before Scott but I'll tell it to
everybody here and then we'll take some
more questions if anybody has any so I
bought do as Holy Diver at a record star
here in Wisconsin and Waukesha actually
you know while I was walking downtown
from Catholic Memorial High School where
I was like a new freshman and this this
this guy who I was carpooling with he's
like let's go downtown and go to the
record stores like yeah it sounds good
to me
and we go to the metal section he's like
you should get this album and and I
didn't know enough about like you know
what was going on at the time to have an
idea about who I should buy and I was
like okay I guess I'll I'll get this and
to me you know I was like the the
lettering and you know I didn't really
pay that close attention to the rest of
the stuff on the album cover and so I
take it home and we've got is this
demonic figure you know throwing a
priest clearly a priest because he's got
like a collar and stuff
who apparently it was throwing him in by
his chain into a lake and the priest
looks pretty upset about it and so I get
this : and I'm listening to it and I'm
like all this is amazing stuff and my
mom found the album cover and she just
hit the roof you know this is terrible I
really got to remember too this is
around the time that like there was the
moral panic I'm heavy metal and Satanism
and they're really there's nothing
satanic about the thing at all well and
it didn't look good look great to me did
not look good to my mom you know this is
this is an interesting future topic is
around this time we had a whole I mean
everything in in pop culture okay if we
take film Footloose or the club was
always the misunderstood teens against
the over conservative stupid parents but
with the tipper gore we want the warning
labels on where Frank Zappa showed up so
it might be an interesting topic as far
as society morality ethics and the shock
value that you know they're like yeah
you know like the 70s wasn't so shocking
but the 80s really gotten especially
with MTV it was you know pretty much
about sex and partying everything yeah
you know it's interesting this is this
is sort of like flipping all the way
across the iron curtain there were these
lists that that Soviet the Soviet within
the USSR there within this you know
Soviet republic and also within the
Warsaw Pact countries certain music
groups were banned and they included a
lot of metal bands and they included a
lot of punk bands and they would have
reasons for it it could be like you know
a cult or you know promoting sexual
promiscuity and stuff like that and you
read through these lists or drug use is
another big one you read through through
these lists and there's two things that
strike you about it one is just how
arbitrary the labeling was or you'd be
like well so you gave Judas Priest this
but you didn't give this to a venom yeah
like they they didn't know what marry
well you know the
the thing was just how conservative they
were culturally well that yeah well even
here I mean this stuff that we hear on
radio with rap axes you know but but
back then remember it was the age of
backward satanic messages that weren't
right right and we would play our
records backward and you wouldn't hear a
damn thing stairway to heaven it says
this and we used to play the records
backwards and go I don't I didn't hear
it it's like but it was um parent groups
it was I mean it was all church churches
you know or get involved the media - I
mean Geraldo was was probably the worst
instigator for that you know and he
would try to get hold special its
genomic Commons and Louis denominator on
his show to prove his point he wouldn't
take you know you know somebody that
could speak intelligently he'd find some
band in the bar that were Satanists but
didn't know what Satanism was and you
know it was kind of like but it was an
interesting era because socially you
know with the album covers they became
more explicit the lyrics are then I
think MTV really blew it up like
whatever look who said here we should
all talk about like Carl says we should
share stories about when our parents
found out and yeah I remember the cover
that shocked I think my my parents first
one I remember was was Aziz you know the
live one the live one with Brad Gillis
why am I forgetting everything today
where he Kelly's moving out of his mouth
yeah I I don't know which one that that
is how you definitely do it's the one
it's anyway see he has his mouth open
there's like jelly
this must be blood coming out of his
mouth it's the one it's all Sabbath
covers when did that one come out eighty
to eighty it's right so Brad Gillis
finished the Randy Rhoads tour okay
and then somebody on here knows what I'm
talking about
God I'm just this lack of sleep
yeah I'm sorry I don't know which one
that is but but I mean Ozzy was also
this is something kind of worth noting
he was in was it it was a Halloween type
movie Andy and I watched it a long time
ago and I think it might have also had
gene Simmons in it
Ozzy was like actually a preacher in it
and ahead fast way a trick-or-treat Andy
oh yeah right and it had fast way as the
soundtrack is it's basically like the
third fastway album speak of the devil
sorry sinner thank you oh yeah yeah okay
that's right and I just looked it up -
they changed the album cover the album
cover now is him and Brad Gillis
together like in a moment on stage Oh
interesting I mean nowadays you'd think
they'd be less prudish about that sort
of thing unless it has to do with like
underage kids you know all of the
scorpions or well I suppose two other
sexually explicit themes well you know
like they a lot of the album's like
invasion of your privacy with rat you
know it wasn't an indecent but they had
like this you know sexy very suggestive
Justin and it was perfect for the coming
of age 15 year old boys right and 16
year old boys kind of you know it was
kind of a sex drugs rock n roll era yeah
but you know it was really now looking
back you know we're not that stuff
anymore no I think McGee is the the
doors have been blown so so wide open
you know largely through the the
internet well let's let's ask if there's
any other comments or questions here's
there's one an interesting one for me
Andy I think you need to do a whole show
about how teenage girls were involved in
the metal scene in the 1980s especially
if we weren't groupies but actual fans
based on musicality and that's a good
idea that's a great idea because just
being a musician in that time and in
bands there was we were kind of a
subculture I mean even just by
definition any of a
that were metal lovers were kind of like
the subculture we were kind of the yeah
underdog so to speak but there was
always women in that group you know and
I remember being at the mall because we
used to hang out at the mall we tell our
parents were going to movies the movies
but we you know walk around and there'd
be girls with iron begging t-shirts and
we'd go up the irons if you didn't know
who you would always like pay the
respect and it was kind of a subculture
but not groupies not anymore than we
were right so we were just fans yeah
also a lot of women into plain girls
that were starting to play in bands or
sing that we're kind of really wanting
to do it yeah and there I mean there
were some acts that were kind of not
great you know I mean there were a lot
of male acts that were not great they
were there's kind of trying to
capitalize on it but then there were
some others i you know i i've thought
about doing some maybe a section where
we talked about like some of the
lesser-known either female fronted or
entirely female bands like girls school
or acid from belgium or you know some of
these other bands but it's also worth
pointing out that one of the most
important researchers on heavy metal who
is i think still down at the University
of Chicago I want to say is Donna
Weinstein who she's probably I imagine
she was probably in her late teens in
the 70s and so she kind of came up with
it and she's the one who did a lot of
the really important research that paved
the way for taking heavy metal seriously
it's an academic topic
she wrote a sociology of heavy metal
that that's quite good and it came out
the book I think came out in 1990 but it
was drawing on all this research that
she'd done throughout the 80s you
mentioned that I got a I got to pick
that up and Suzi Quatro yes yeah nice
nice you know in and we always credit as
far as the eighties you know post The
Runaways vixen was you know in that hole
oh yeah I forgot about them yeah rich
Marx was writing their stuff or some of
their stuff okay I thought they were
fantastic and oddly enough just a
shout-out to my friend Brittany is the
current guitarist in that band so
they're still active well yeah I mean
yeah I saw her come through with them a
few times she's obviously the youngest
person in the band but I think yeah yeah
those those records were great and they
were really important and I remember on
MTV them kind of trash-talking like
we're just as good as the guys and they
were kind of emerging in a in something
that was very male-dominated ironically
though yeah writing up as women like you
know know so well thinking about like
classic Motley Crue and like shout at
the devil right or poison right from the
New York Dolls kind of Cinderella yeah
Ella but I thought they were fantastic
and they really I think they paved the
way after that for not female acts like
Fiona or something but but like bands
that were all female just yeah okay and
you know another thing that we should
mention in light of that and then let's
let's take a raschi's question and as
like we'll do that was the last question
I think about the tanks were way over
time um there's also these this
interesting phenomenon of all-female
cover bands that take male bands and
then you know they play all their stuff
and transform it like the iron maidens
or judas priestess or there's got to be
one with kiss I'm sure maybe maybe
several of them you know I have a
student it's starting one and I don't
know what what's what's the band that
she's doing I don't know I don't know
the name I and so friend that I grew up
with she was in a band called girl when
I was in a band this side of seven this
is a long time ago but then she said I'm
looking to do a kiss tribute band and
she wants to do the 80s kiss Oh
interesting and she said she's gonna
have a few of the old stuff but one of
my students ended up showing interest
and the band was formed but of course
has been put on halt because of the time
the rim yeah but
I'm sure there's one if you google
there's probably an all-female kiss yeah
that's that that I'm sure there's
probably several of them out there so
rash says I'd love to hear you speak
more about the guy stood metal of the
spirit or mind of metal metals ambiguous
transgress in relation to religion in
the occult spirituality of metal the
emotional range of expressions those are
a lot of things you mentioned the Donna
Weinstein book which probably touches a
lot of these these things none of that
is fixed or static of course but there's
general characteristics so yeah I think
there there is something that you could
call like the underlying spirit of metal
it's tied in with the the the sonic
characteristics and it's also tied in to
some degree with lyrics and life style
and this is why I we can actually at
some point so I'm not going to provide a
full answer here but this is why at some
point we can say you know this is metal
and this isn't metal you know like doing
this thing over here like when we say
that that that for example rainbow that
the stuff with Graham bonnet
you know like Street of Dreams right
made it unto masters of metal but it
didn't really belong there it's not
really metal and so I think yeah that
that's that's actually a great question
what what constitutes this animating
spirit and part of that is also you're
right it is something changing because
the community itself plays a role in
that and the last thing I'll say about
that is the fact that metal has now
split into all these different genres I
think shows us something about maybe the
multi multi faceted nature of that
because because a lot of these genres
are sort of like taking one or two
aspects of metal and emphasizing those
to the extreme it's like sort of like
the equivalent of hyper specialization
within an environment you know and and
the best ones are usually where there's
some like some looking back to some
previous tradition
and incorporating them and doing
something new with them or you know
going across the genres I would say but
I mean that's and that's my perspective
I'm not a I'm not a big John reversal
Scott what do you think about that and
I'll let you have the last word
yes ethics to God that's that you know I
think the subculture there's a sub-genre
thing right now is something I don't
even comprehend I mean I have students
coming and you know I guess the spirit
of it I mean we have to we'd have to go
back to the eerie you're talking about
you know arguably where it started the
70s and in the 80s even through like the
the LA scene you know 80s what was the
spirit of it I mean to me I keep saying
it was kind of like the people that were
most like involved in metal seem to be
the quiet outcasts and I was you know I
was certainly that and it was kind of a
I think you didn't he was sonic it
wasn't really to me back then you know
sometimes it might be but it was kind of
you know I think it created a world I
mean you know look even to some degree
deals theatrical you have you know when
you listen to it you're in a different
world right so it's not a dance album
where you listen and say oh I'm happy
I'm you know you don't have like a Rick
Astley album ongoing this is fun and
that's a great thing too but I think
what these even kiss were cartoon
characters I think like rainbow it was
all about it transforms you into another
world and I think for me that was unique
and it was a sonic nosov it that yeah
yeah so it was kind of like a different
world you can escape into and whereas
like you know I love pop radio too but
it didn't supply the same experience
right yeah we can speak of a metal
imaginary maybe in a way right and we
could talk about subdivisions of that
too I mean there's like the let's party
in we're gonna we're going to get it on
and it's going to be not romance
but it's gonna be sexy and dirty you
know we'll also get drunk in the process
and that could be like rat and kiss and
I also you know some a deep purple and
definitely white snake um and then you
have like you know Steve Harris you know
talking about Iron Maiden saying and we
didn't want to do romantic songs you
know and and that there there's very I
mean there are a few relationships in
that like think about revelations on
peace of mind but it's all in this very
mystical Eden for me it was those long
they would always go into these middle
sections of these dreamy kind of twin
guitar parts that were and the bass
would change under the same day yeah and
so for me that was kind of like the
journey in my head I'd go through if I
had to crank it it with headphones at
night so it was you know um that's a
great example of how the sonic allottee
sort of supports the the what's going on
in the imagination I mean for me this
the Scorpions are like that too you know
I've said before that I think Rudolf
Schenker is one of the best songwriters
out there in in metal and part of it is
because of what's all the different
layers to what's what's happening and
then that you know the earlier stuff at
the Lully John Roth mmm-hmm you know the
way he played was just I didn't know
what he was doing when I was younger but
I really enjoyed and then of course with
Matthias jabs when he came in he was
fantastic but that was a different one
that was kind of like the big city
nights and all that I love them both but
yeah I think the sonic miss yeah I
really liked how a lot of the live I was
like big worldwide live I wore that
album out even though I had all the
previous records it was just so alive
and it was just kind of like you hear
the crowd roar and you were part of
something right so yeah Chris says I
come in here kiss me something on TV
when I was young I had nightmares really
you know but then I watched it years
later and it's I I own it actually
because they put it out on a box set but
um they admitted to not knowing what
what was going on they just read scenes
and it was put together
later yeah so so Chris says when you
roll credits have deal
Holy Diver playing I wish that we could
you know and this is we could do like
actually do a whole episode on the
current electronic digital landscape we
can't because YouTube has all these BOTS
that that crawl everything that ever
goes up on there and if you even get
like a scintilla of something that
that's in their copyright stuff playing
they'll take you down in an instant I've
seen it happen and it can just be like
somebody else playing in the background
you know that that's the mouse to get
you flagged I mean any other comments or
questions or stuff before we we close up
what were you think Scott well we wait
for I did a did a transcription of a
Herbie Hancock solo and you know I
remember this yeah yeah so in the
background the records playing he's
playing piano and I'm playing exactly
what he's playing on guitar but Biggs
flagged it and I'm thinking well it was
only like two minutes of it and it was
me playing but somebody heard the music
in the background I made a bot probably
heard it and shut me down
no I argued it was for educational
purposes and they let it go back up Oh
interesting yeah because it was it was
Joe yeah it was me hearing like how you
would use this to inspire you or give
you new ideas there is like this notion
of fair use but every time that I tried
to research it it's so loosey-goosey and
and everybody says well the courts will
decide it for you and you're like well
who wants to go to court
all right let's let's do it again here
Carl says Andy is he asking to tell the
story of how I'm on a Black Sabbath
album it's too long a story to tell just
know oh and I'll type it up and cut
pasted for next time that sounds great
yeah I thought it would be that'd be
excellent yeah and you know Carl we
could always we can always hand you on
as a guest speaker if you want to do
that that could be quite quite
interesting to do alright let's wrap it
up we okay well we'll read it aloud
we'll read it out loud for you exactly
that sounds great all right so hopefully
this this clarified to some degree this
this thing that we call the Black
Sabbath deep purple Nexus and and you
know well we'll definitely be posting
what we're doing I'm gonna try to get
ahead of this and post a couple topics
in advance
now that the semester is almost done so
thanks for everybody for joining in and
questions thanks again Scott for for
being here it's always a great time
accounter session with you too thank you
no it's this is great yeah all right
so have a great whatever it is in your
time zone morning afternoon evening and
we'll see you next month